[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
show my friends Texas has a bill which
would ban nearly all gender affirming
care
but not just for children for Trans
adults adults who you would think under
the sort of right-wing view should be
allowed to basically do whatever they
want as long as they want to do it and
it's not harming anybody else but this
is a build that is triggering alarm
among LGBT advocates in Texas who say
the way that Texas has written this bill
would make nearly all gender affirming
care illegal this includes Surgical and
non-surgical treatments even for adults
even for adults a quality Texas says
while we've seen several bills that
would criminalize life-saving health
care for Trans people none go as far as
this the bill bans any Public Funding
for Trans Health Care at any age and
puts impossible constraints on medical
professionals and insurance providers in
addition to that Public Funding aspect
which is really important for low-income
individuals because Hey listen you
you're allowed to be trans and
low-income that doesn't mean you
shouldn't have access to the appropriate
care that you and your medical providers
determine is right for you
um they also are uh going if the bill
passes they would increase legal
liability through malpractice suits for
the medical professionals that provide
gender affirming care the
um Bill also lists as gender affirming
procedures any surgeries performed on
the genitals mastectomies and
prescriptions of puberty blockers or
hormones quote for the purpose of
transitioning a patient patient's
biological sex or affirming the
patient's perception of the patient's
sex which is extraordinarily broad as
well so this is horrifying this is only
one of more than 70 anti-lgbt bills that
Texas has introduced during this year's
legislative session it's not it's not
even March yet so this is chilling we
worried about this uh but all you can do
is put one foot in front of the other
and do what you can to defeat these
bills Pat yeah in a sense this is The
Logical conclusion that they wouldn't
just be targeting uh gender affirming
care as it pertains to children but they
would also do so as it pertains to
adults and you know we sort of
facetiously say things like oh well I'm
surprised Republicans would want to do
this because they're all for personal
choice personal Liberty once you're an
adult you can make your own decisions
yeah but we've seen on so many other
issues they don't actually act that way
I mean they're still trying to ban gay
marriage for example and that is an
issue that exclusively has to deal with
adults yes and you know the rights who
enter contracts and do the types of
things that they want with their own
bodies and relationships and that sort
of thing and they also moved last year
to get rid of Roe versus Wade to open up
states of being able to ban abortion and
So that obviously also has to do with
adults largely who are going to be
making decisions about their their own
bodies and so you know maybe to some
degree I'm a little surprised they're
doing this so early because you'd think
that they would spend another year or
two just trying to focus on gender firm
and care as it pertains to children
because maybe they could see that as
more of a winning issue for them yeah
but no in Texas they're already going
for the adults they're already giving
away the game showing what they want to
do and we shouldn't be surprised at all
that this is the direction that they're
going in but maybe it's okay be a little
surprised in how early it's happening
and as usual you know but by going to
the extreme they actually prevent
serious conversations about questions
that should be answered I mean I get
emails I just got an email in fact from
a progressive doctor
who is a defender of trans rights and
everything right but she also said you
know the early studies on the use of
puberty blockers raise some real
questions about the long-term health
effects it's often reflexively said the
effect is temporary and there's no
long-term effect but there are growing
numbers of studies that are some that
that are complete some that are being
done that raise questions about
osteoporosis and uh biological females
who take the blog things that exceed my
personal knowledge of someone who's not
a doctor but there's stuff we have to
figure out there's legitimate things
that we should figure out but we can't
do it in a reasonable way because every
conversation is Tainted by anti-trans
extremism from people like those in the
Texas legislature yeah that's the thing
I mean there's so much hubris on this
issue uh in the right wing they act as
if they're experts on this really what's
going on is they are perturbed by the
idea of it or they have some sort of
transphobia or they feel as though kids
aren't actually trans or you know
feeling as if they belong to a different
body than the one that they have really
what's going on is that they're just
confused and they need more God in their
life and that's going to solve
everything yeah these people that are
putting forward these bills these
lawmakers and The Advocates like have
they actually looked into these issues I
don't get the sense that they have no
yeah like you point out there can be
Nuance with this stuff because a lot of
it is newer right I mean a lot of
evidence points to how you know puberty
blockers and gender affirming care can
be quite beneficial for people and you
can look at the data it doesn't mean
every issue is solved on it but we can't
even really have an honest conversation
when the right isn't even willing to
explore the topic yet and yet they're
willing to come to conclusion
um that are totally nonsense nonsensical
and non-serious on this one important
thing I think to mention is this
particular Bill we're talking about is
unlikely to pass based on the legal
analyzes we've seen but it's part of
these more than 70 bills in total many
of them may well pass some have and the
the sort of cumulative effect is
completely chilling but let's at least
hope this one does not pass it seems as
though the Apple doesn't fall far from
the tree when it comes to paying legal
bills lawyers for Steve Bannon the
former Trump Aid and Breitbart
propagandist are now suing him for
unpaid legal pills uh the law firm uh
Davidoff hutcher and Citron said in a
lawsuit they filed that Bannon hasn't
paid for the work they did he owes them
480 000 in legal fees and other Bannon
attorneys are looking to end their work
over a Communications breakdown where
they are unable to meaningfully
communicate with their with their client
um Reuters was unable to immediately
confirm who is still representing Bannon
at this point in time it's really
unclear so you know as usual the
um same story that we've seen before and
the the level of you know I've had to
make decisions about legal assistance in
the past
and it would but first of all usually
they're asking for a retainer and
although when it's small jobs I just say
just bill me and then I'll pay for it it
would never even remotely occur to me
not to pay my legal bills now is it
possible that I could end up in a
situation with millions of dollars in
legal fees and I have to accept
council's help because I just need to
and then I don't have the money and then
so I don't pay it's conceivable that I
could end up in such a situation but the
fact that this is a trend among these
folks Trump doesn't pay his legal bills
and now Bannon doesn't pay his legal
bills there's a sort of uh audacity to
it that is quite stunning I kind of get
the sense that folks like Trump and
Bannon could be doing this because they
already have to deal with so many
headaches when it comes to litigation uh
you know be it civil matters or criminal
matters that are just ongoing that never
seem to end and maybe so they fig maybe
they figure like okay well if I just
don't pay my legal bills maybe
eventually I'll get sued over it and
there'll be like a couple of Court
appearances I have to make but
ultimately the judge could decide in my
favor or they could say that I'm
judgment proof or I'll have to pay a
smaller amount of money like if this
sort of thing happened to you or me we'd
think okay we don't want to even deal
with the headache we're just gonna pay
the bills because we did after all hire
these lawyers and that's what you have
to do at the end of the day but
regardless of if Trump or Bannon pay
their legal bills they're still going to
have so many legal proceedings to deal
with stuff to be concerned about so like
maybe they just figure it makes sense to
save the money in the short term and
maybe by the time this actually uh is
litigated they will be out of money or
they'll be like serving a prison
sentence in a bannon's case and
ultimately the problem will just go away
maybe so and the total bill for Bannon
appears to have been 855 000 he paid 375
and that's where we get the the 480 that
that's outstanding you know another
important lesson from all of this stuff
is
it can get very expensive when you get
involved in the sort of hijinks that
they these guys got involved in
including you know being held in
contempt lying to investigate all these
different things many of which are kind
of self uh they're unforced errors to a
certain degree now being involved in the
highest Echelon of politics to begin
with does carry some risk even if your
intentions are completely on the up and
up when they aren't and it includes
things like lying and then being held in
contempt and all these you're only
creating a worse situation for yourself
which gets very expensive
I mean maybe they run the numbers though
maybe they predict what it's going to
cost them ultimately in legal fees and
the rest of it to run some sort of scam
having to do with building the wall and
fundraising or they assess what it's
going to cost them to decide to be in
contempt of congress by not
participating uh in the January 6th
investigation and they say okay well
I'll be able to raise this much money
off of uh how I'm so aggrieved over the
charges that I'm facing I'll be able to
you know up my cache within right-wing
circles get more audience attention on
me they'll buy my products and that sort
of thing and so yeah I'll be down 2
million from the expenses but I'll be up
3 million from however much and there's
a profit there I mean it seems like
incredibly difficult to run the numbers
on that sort of thing because you can't
predict everything right it's risky but
these people maybe they just like to
live life on the edge and they think
that they can do it and I do think that
they're definitely thinking about the
money when they make these types of
decisions these are very very risky
calculations to make but that doesn't
mean you're wrong about that a Florida
lawyer is arguing that a pregnant
inmate's fetus is being illegally
detained I find this extraordinarily
interesting because it does follow
logically from the idea that a fetus is
a person we're talking about a woman
named Natalia Harrell who has been
jailed she's 24 she's been jailed
without bonds since July because she was
accused of fatally shooting Another
Woman She's been charged with
second-degree murder at the time of the
arrest she was six weeks pregnant she's
now eight months pregnant and she says
that the staff at the jail have
endangered the fetus by refusing her
proper prenatal care putting her in
situations involving extremely high heat
in inmate transport Vans and all sorts
of other things so her lawyer has now
filed a petition
where he says the unborn child is
innocent and should be discharged from
jail so that it can receive proper care
because the child is as of yet dependent
on the mother's body you've got to
release the mother as well and he writes
the unborn child has rights independent
of its mother even though it is still
physically dependent on the mother the
child has been deprived of due process
of the law in this incarceration and it
has to be a factor in figuring this
entire thing out now the argument
assumes The Unborn Child is a person
based on the definition under the
Florida Constitution this gets us to
fetal personhood which is a big issue
under
abortion debates
I've said before
if indeed the fetus is a person at the
moment of conception or whenever then it
would follow that the fetus could get
citizenship and it would follow that you
could have child support awarded over a
fetus and all of these different things
it would follow that if an undocumented
immigrant woman
uh becomes pregnant in the United States
because the fetus is a person it's like
the fetus now has been born and thus has
citizenship based on how we award
citizenship and so you can't Deport a
pregnant woman because there's a U.S
citizen in the womb and this is sort of
another one of the things that indeed
would follow from that fetal personhood
framework absolutely I think there are
maybe two issues as it pertains to this
story because regardless of if you
consider the fetus to be a human being
or not this woman should be able to
receive the appropriate parental care
she shouldn't be put in uh transport
vans that are too hot and that sort of
thing so even outside of the abortion
and Fetal rights sort of uh argument you
can definitely make the case that she
should be more properly treated here I
also uh wonder if this is going to be
the most effective case in trying to
push for like a pro-choice argument
given the fact that you're dealing with
someone who is on trial for
second-degree murder and it's going to
be difficult for people to maybe
empathize eyes with someone in that sort
of situation like it's like when we talk
about the death penalty being barbaric
for example and uh someone who is put to
death having to suffer a bunch because
like the lethal injection isn't working
properly or what have you there are a
lot of people who turn around and say
well that person killed five people
including a grandma and so why should I
waste my sympathy on them so it can
sometimes be difficult for us to make
that sort of argument I kind of get the
same sense with this one and so that's
why like maybe when it pertains to this
issue it's better to focus on stories
like that woman who is driving in the
HOV lane because she was pregnant she
didn't have any other passengers in the
car but she got a ticket over that and
that caused this National story like
people can more easily identify with
someone like that and feel sympathy and
so when it comes to just like sort of
our focus when it pertains to this issue
I think we should maybe choose carefully
but it doesn't mean that this isn't an
interesting story without without a
doubt and I don't know ultimately what
the outcome is going to be and then of
course a eight months means we are
starting to get close to when you would
expect that baby to be born and what is
going to happen at that point in time
and it it's all it's horrible in a whole
bunch of different ways it raises
ethical questions it raises
philosophical questions legal questions
questions about uh treatment in in
prison and this is going to be a story
that doesn't end here that's for sure I
also get the sense that as we are
approaching this issue we make it seem
as though oh well right Wingers will
have to answer to this right they'll
have to pick whatever principle they're
in favor of they'll have no they won't
have to remain consistent on all these
different things and then we realize oh
yeah they'll just do what they normally
do which is pick and choose go with
whatever benefits them at the time and
there's there's no consistency they
don't actually care about that sort of
and the voters don't care either so
there's no downside to being
inconsistent as we've talked about
before all right everybody we will see
you tomorrow new show and new bonus show
[Music]